- I'm here today, going
to play Google Feud,
where I guess the top
search things in Google.
- I will be looking at
different categories, and then
I will be guessing what there
are the most searched Google
queries. I would say I'm fairly
in tune with the internet.
I like to Google myself sometimes,
see what I'm up to. Not very much.
- Let's play Google Feud.
- The windy city. (chimes)
Yeah, I got that correct.
There it is, 10,000.
The windy mill? (buzzer) Nope.
The windy, the windy, the
windy, the windy, the windy,
the windy, the windy. What other windy?
Windy, the windy, the windy people?
(buzzer) Nope. That's two X's.
What other things can you put
after windy? The windy
(laughing). I sound like an idiot.
The windy music? (buzzer) No. Three X's.
These are the answers. The windy
apple. What the f--- is the
windy apple? The Windy City Assassin.
So I'm guessing that's
probably a serial killer
or something, which is a great name.
The Windy City Assassin.
That's a good one.
The windy road. Oh! It's not windy,
it's winding. That makes
so much more sense.
- How does Google autocomplete this query?
Chocolate flavored...
Chocolate flavored ice cream.
(buzzer) No!? No one's
Googling chocolate flavored
ice cream? Okay, wait, I gotta
think of the person that is
Googling a thing. See,
they don't need to Google
chocolate flavored ice cream because
they already know what that is.
Chocolate flavored Oreos. (buzzer) What!?
Okay, I'm gonna do one, not
because I thought of it,
but because this is what
I think of the internet.
Let's just make that really clear.
Mom and Dad, turn off this video.
Condoms. (buzzer) No!
Now I sound like a creep!
Coffee. Beer. Why didn't I
think of any of these things?
- I think my mom is crazy.
(buzzer) That's not one of them?
Okay. Drunk. Two X's. Wow. Okay.
What do people search about
their mom? I think my mom is
a serial killer. Three X's.
I'm seeing the answers now.
A lot of these do make sense.
I think my mom is gay.
I don't think my mom is.
I think my mom is a super
hero. Very sweet. That's not
possibly true though because
super heroes aren't real.
There are only two positive
ones which is, being a
super hero, and amazing, and
amazing being the thousand
point one. I find that sad because
you know what, my mom is amazing.
- Thomas. Okay. Thomas
An... No. Thomas Adams.
(buzzer)
I put Adams with one D, and
then I put Adams with two D's,
and neither of them. Oh, wait,
I have to think of popular
people online, don't I? Because
they're not gonna Google
Thomas Adams. He's not
popular. I'm such a dork.
Oh, Thomas Jefferson's probably
not one either, is it then?
Thomas Sanders. (buzzer) What? (grunting)
Thomas Jefferson was the first
one and I said no one would
Google that. No! I've gotten zero right
in this whole game so far.
- What is the address of
The White House? (chimes)
Number one. What is the
address of Donald Trump?
(buzzer) That's not one? Oh, interesting.
I was very confident on
that one. Such is life.
Who's a celebrity that
creepy guys would wanna
send their dirty socks to?
Jennifer Lawrence. (buzzer) Nope.
The president. (buzzer) Nope. Oh f--- off.
What is the address of
where I am? The North Pole.
Santa Claus. Oh, that's sweet.
Probably a child Googled that
because they do not know
that Santa Claus is not real.
I wish he were real.
- How to draw a circle. (buzzer)
I guess no one has to Google that.
Cartoon. (buzzer) I wanna
know how to draw a cartoon.
I can't believe that's not in the top 10.
How to draw a dog. (chimes)
That was number one!
I got one number one.
I'll never get it again.
How to draw a cat. (buzzer) Nope.
No one asked how to draw a
cat? How did turkey beat cat?
- I think it's a very fun
game. We all use Google, so you
would think you'd be familiar
with the searching habits of
other people, but I guess at
the end of the day you just
kind of know your own searching habits.
- I do not have the same
consciousness as the internet.
My brain does not work, and
I would also be garbage at
Family Feud. If my family had
decided to do Family Feud,
I would have been removed
from my family, and replaced
with someone else.
(jazzy music)